[Music]  I'm Megan do you want to hang out  again Megan Megan is so sweet and nice  great job Katie Megan has so much  personality it's insane right she's like  a homeschool teacher best friend the  ideal companion I won't let anything  harm you she's just this effervescent  beaming ray of light until she goes  batch crazy  in a purple this film is intense iconic  strange constantly unsettling when the  head just goes like that  no that was very creepy you should  probably run  go see this movie in a theater  make you unplug all your devices I have  a new primary user now  yeah people might have a bit of an  uneasy sleep over this one  [Music]  nothing bad happens it's a comedy  um  [Music]